we're learning new details this morning
about the attack that killed four
American soldiers in a remote village in
the West African country of Nazaire last
month ambushed by Isis linked militants
took place near tango tango never Potter
made her way to the site of the attack
to find out how it unfolded she's in New
Jersey capital Nami with what she
learned
Deborah good morning good morning the
journey to the ambush site was a round
trip of 12 hours on Nigeria and military
escort was still jittery after last
month's attack and not keen to linger
giving us less than half an hour on the
ground the village of Tongo Tongo on the
treacherous border between these year
and Mali is so remote you can't even
find a road that leads to it on a map
this is where Nigerian and American
troops stopped to get water before they
were ambushed as they were leaving a
chilling sight a village elder who was
so nervous he asked to speak to us at
another location told us a few mins
suddenly appeared on motorbikes the
preferred mode of transport for Isis
fighters it was just a few terrorists he
says we think if it's just a few
terrorists the soldiers can kill them
easily but we didn't know there were so
many more of them waiting nearby it was
a trap once the Isis fighters had
managed to lure the troops away from the
village the numbers multiplied and
suddenly they were under attack you can
still see the bullet casings that are
left over from the intense shooting the
elder told us there are about 20
motorbikes with two men on each armed
with either ak-47s or RPGs and at least
10 vehicles which descended on the
troops terrified he hidden his home
throughout the fighting which lasted
well over two hours all that's left now
are the fragmented remnants of a
battleground the burnt-out shell of a
small one-room school blood-stained
bushes smoke grenades and empty boxes of
ammunition
the village elder told us the terrorists
often cross over the border to launch
attacks but he's never seen anything
like the battle that raged at Tongo
Tongo Gail yes Deborah thank you very
jarring to see those bullet casings
knowing how that ended up thank you very
much